we begin with this firefighters in
Southern California are battling another
massive wildfire a huge area of the
state is now in flames
the new fire in San Diego County erupted
yesterday and it exploded in size dry
and windy conditions are fueling these
flames more than 500 homes and other
buildings have been destroyed across a
region more than 190,000 people are
under evacuation orders and at least one
person has been killed six major fires
are now raging across Southern
California they have burned more than
220 square miles Carter Evans is in
Bonsall California near the new fire
Carter good morning good morning we
watched as this home burned down last
night and you can actually see what it
looked like as firefighters battled to
beat back the flames it's just one of
about a dozen homes that burned in this
fast-moving fire that still has not led
up as the fire spread from home to home
firefighters worked endlessly to stop it
in its tracks fierce winds above 35
miles per hour carried embers through
the air putting more than a thousand
structures in danger at first this crew
had no access to a hydrant leaving them
with only 500 gallons of water to try
and contain the flames when firefighters
came across this home it was already
burning you can see they're putting a
lot of water on it right now but it's
hardly doing anything at this point
they're just trying to keep the flames
from spreading the lilac fire in San
Diego County
exploded to more than 40 100 acres in
just a few hours Thursday these are
fully involved there's nothing we can do
about it we're gonna let those burn down
to the ground we have crews surrounded
this whole area
we're gonna make a stand and we're gonna
protect all the ones that we can several
homes in this community were incinerated
while others just down the street were
untouched the lilac fire is just the
latest in a string of fires tearing
through Southern California's since
Monday officials are concerned shifting
winds expected today could cause the
largest of those the thomas fire in
Ventura County to scorch other
communities at least 439 structures have
burned so far in this fire back at this
horse training center in San Diego
County people were forced to set
hundreds of thoroughbreds free from
their burning barns they say about 25
horses died while trying to escape
Jennifer Bramblett helped rescue some
from a field nearby everybody's just
grabbing horses we're trying barns and
burned down that are here what's it like
to know you may not be able to save them
all I think we've caught most of the
loose ones several school districts in
San Diego have closed down for the day
this hot windy weather is unusual this
close to winter and by the way gale
firefighters say it could take weeks for
all these flames to die down it looks
like something out of a movie Carter
believes be careful you and everybody
else thank you very much